ADDRESSING GREEN NEW DEAL WHICH
RECEIVE ZERO VOTES.
BRET.
>> Bret: LET'S TALK ABOUT ALL
THAT, THANK YOU.
CINEMA MAJORITY LEADER MITCH
McCONNELL.
MR. LEADER, THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE, BERNIE SANDERS PUT OUT A
STATEMENT BY
PRESIDENT BERNIE SANDERS WILL
GET MEDICARE FOR ALL THROUGH.
HE IS PUSHING FOR A FILIBUSTER
REFORM.
HE SAID IT WILL GET 51 VOTES.
DEMOCRATIC SENATORS QUOTE NEED
TO BE PREPARED TO DO WHAT POLLS
SHOW THE DEMOCRATS WANT AND THAT
IS MEDICARE FOR ALL SINGLE-PAYER
SYSTEM.
YOUR REACTION.
YOUR REACTION TO THAT.
>> Mitch: NOT AS LONG AS I'M
MAJORITY LEADER.
IT OUGHT TO BE COLD MEDICARE FOR
NONE.
BECAUSE I WAS SET AT PEACE
180 MILLION AMERICANS WOULD LOSE
PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCE.
THEY HAVE NEGOTIATED FOR.
MEDICARE ITSELF THE CURRENT
RECIPIENTS PAYING INTO ALL THESE
YEARS WOULD BE COMPLETELY
DRAINED BY ADDING ALL OF THESE
INITIAL PEOPLE.
YOU WANT TO TURN AMERICA INTO A
SOCIALIST COUNTRY THIS IS THE
FIRST.
THAT COUPLED WITH THE GREEN NEW
DEAL, WHICH ELIMINATES A LOT OF
JOBS.
I THINK WHAT WE SEE HERE IS
FULL, SOCIALISM ON DISPLAY AND
THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY FOR
PRESIDENT.
AND EVEN THOSE WHO ARE SKEPTICAL
ABOUT IT LIKE SENATOR KLOBUCHAR
ARE SAYING THE PUBLIC OPTION.
THAT IS NOT MUCH DIFFERENT
BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE A PUBLIC
OPTION I GUARANTEE THE PUBLIC
OPTION WOULD ALSO DRIVE ALL THE
PRIVATE INSURANCE COMPANIES OUT
OF BUSINESS.
SO LOOK, THIS, THIS IS A
PRESCRIPTION FOR TURNING AMERICA
INTO WESTERN EUROPEAN COUNTRY.
>> Bret: WHERE IS THE G.O.P.
PLAN ON HEALTH CARE?
>> Mitch: WELL, WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE EVERYBODY KNOWS IS
THAT WE ARE ALL IN FAVOR OF
COVERING PRE-EXISTING
CONDITIONS.
AND THAT IS REALLY NOT IN DANGER
OF THE CURRENT LITIGATION
WORKING ITS WAY THROUGH THE
COURTS.
I'M ALL IN FAVOR OF WORKING ON
WHAT SHOULD BE CALLED NICHE
FIXES TO TRY TO IMPROVE THE
CURRENT SYSTEM.
OBVIOUSLY, OBAMACARE HAS
ENTIRELY TOO HIGH AT COPAYMENTS
AND DEDUCTIBLES.
WE OUGHT TO BE WORKING ON
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
THERE IS A BIPARTISAN EFFORT
UNDERWAY IN THE SENATE TO TRY TO
GET DOWN THE COST OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT COULD ACTUALLY PASS, BUT I
GUARANTEE YOU, NEXT YEAR WHAT IT
WILL BE ON DISPLAY ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IS A DEBATE ABOUT
WHETHER WE WANT TO TURN AMERICA
INTO A SOCIALIST COUNTRY.
I NEVER THOUGHT, BY THE WAY, WE
WOULD DEBATE CAPITALISM AND
AMERICAN MY LIFETIME.
>> Bret: YOU BACKED OFF LAST
WEEK TAKING ANOTHER RUN AT
TRYING TO REPEAL AND REPLACE
OBAMACARE.
DID THE PRESIDENT GET TOO FAR
OVER HIS SKIS THERE?
>> Mitch: LOOK, WE MADE THAT
EFFORT LAST CONGRESS AND IT
DIDN'T WORK.
CLEARLY DEMOCRATIC HOUSE WILL
NOT PASS IT.
SO WE WILL NOT SPEND TIME IN THE
CENTER ON THINGS THAT HAVE
LITERALLY NO CHANCE OF BECOMING
LAW.
>> Bret: WHAT HAPPENS IF
SUPREME COURT RULES OBAMACARE
AND CONSTITUTIONAL?
>> Mitch: WE WILL HAVE TO
REVISIT THE WHOLE MATTER BUT
THAT'S NOT LIKELY TO HAPPEN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS.
I THINK PEOPLE NEED TO TAKE A
DEEP BREATH AND SETTLE DOWN AND
LET US WORK ON SOME OF THESE
MORE MODEST FIXES THAT I THINK
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED AND
DESERVE.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT
HOW THE PRESIDENT TALKS ABOUT
IT.
HE SAYS GET RID OF OBAMACARE
AFTER THE ELECTION NOW.
>> Mitch: AFTER HE AND I HAD
THIS DISCUSSION, HE INDICATED HE
WOULD COME UP WITH A PLAN AND
RUN ON IT DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
IF THE REPUBLICANS WERE ABLE TO
REGAIN THE HOUSE AND ALL OF THE
SENATE, THAT WOULD BE THE TIME
TO VOTE ON IT.
>> Bret: I WANT TO ASK YOU
SENATOR SANDERS TALKED ABOUT
FILIBUSTERING AND FILIBUSTER
REFORM, YOU EXECUTED THIS
MANEUVER TO SPEED UP THE
CONFIRMATION OF MANY OF THE
PRESIDENT'S NOMINEES.
YOU ARE ON THE RECORD SAYING
THERE ISN'T AN APPETITE TO GET
RID OF LEGISLATIVE FILIBUSTER.
BUT DIDN'T THAT MOVE CRACKED THE
DOOR LITTLE BIT MORE, SUGGESTING
THAT MAYBE THAT IS GOING TO GAIN
SOME STRENGTH WITH LAWMAKERS
THAT THE FILIBUSTER IS NOT GOING
TO BE AROUND FOR LONG?
>> Mitch: LOOK, THIS IS A
LITTLE BIT DOWN IN THE WEEDS FOR
THE VIEWERS, BUT THE SENATE HAS
TWO CALENDARS.
THE LEGISLATIVE AND WE ARE IN
THE PERSONNEL BUSINESS AND THE
HOUSE IS NOT.
THE PERSONNEL AND BUSH 43 WAS
ELECTED ALWAYS HANDLED IN A
FAIRLY SMOOTH WAY WITH A SIMPLE
MAJORITY LEGISLATION IS THE
ESSENCE OF THE SENATE AND
ALWAYS REQUIRED THE SUPER
MAJORITY, AND IT HAS TWO GOOD
EFFECTS.
IT EITHER KILLS OR IT GUARANTEES
BOTH SIDES WORK OUT A
COMPROMISE.
THAT IS THE ESSENCE OF THE
SENATE.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
GEORGE WASHINGTON HOPE THE
SENATE WOULD BECOME.
THAT THINGS WOULD SLOW DOWN, THE
PLACE WHERE THINGS WERE THOUGHT
OVER AND THE PLACE WHERE A LOT
OF BAD IDEAS DIDN'T BECOME LAW.
>> Bret: SO YOU ARE FIGHTING
DEMOCRATS HERE ON THE FILIBUSTER
AND MAY BE THE WHITE HOUSE TOO,
WRITE?
>> Mitch: AT THE PRESIDENT WAS
ANTSY ABOUT THIS BUT I TOLD HIM
WE WEREN'T GOING TO DO IT AND WE
DIDN'T AND I THINK NOW HE'S
PROBABLY THINKING I WAS RIGHT.
>> Bret: I WANT TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THE TESTIMONY TODAY
FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
I GOT A LOT OF ATTENTION TO HEAT
AND HE WAS ASKED IF SPYING ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND HE SAID
YES.
TOP DEMOCRATS REACTED TODAY.
>> THE CONSPIRACY THEORY IS
NONSENSE.
LOOK AT THIS IMAGINARY
CONSPIRACY VERSUS THE FACT THAT
THE RUSSIANS IN REGARD TO THE
ELECTIONS.
>> I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
STATEMENTS MADE BY
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR.
I THINK THEY UNDERMINE OUR
CONSTITUTION.
THEY UNDERMINE THE ROLE OF THE
INTERNAL CHANNEL.
I DON'T TRUST THE SEVEN BUT I
TRUST MUELLER.
>> Mitch: IT'S A PLACE TO
QUESTION WHETHER YOU TRUST BARR
AND AFFIRMED BACK AND BUSH 41,
AN HONORABLE MAN AND NOT TRYING
TO COVER ANYTHING UP.
HE WILL SEND US THE MUELLER
REPORT THAT IS OPEN AS POSSIBLE.
AND WHEN I SAY AS POSSIBLE, I'M
PRETTY CONFIDENT THAT HE IS NOT
GOING TO THROW INNOCENT PEOPLE
THAT WERE NOT CHARGED UNDER THE
BUS AND RUN THEIR REPUTATION OR
REVEAL CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
IF YOU SEND THAT UP TO THE HILL
MY GUARANTEE IT WILL GET OUT.
>> Bret: WHAT ABOUT THE PART
ABOUT THE EARLY PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION?
ARE YOU CONFIDENT BARR AND/OR
SENATE COMMITTEE WILL GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT?
>> Mitch: AGAIN I'M PRETTY
SURE INSPECTOR GENERAL AND
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT LOOKING AT
THAT PARTICULAR PROBLEM.
THAT WAS RELATED TO THE DEPUTY
IN AND THE FBI THAT WAS
DISMISSED.
IT IS WORTH A LOOK AND I THINK
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL AND THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ALREADY
LOOKING AT THAT AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IS RIGHT TO DO THAT.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT SAID TO
DATE IT IS AN ATTEMPT TO COUP AN
ILLEGAL TAKEDOWN OF THE
PRESIDENT AND TREASON.
DO YOU AGREE WITH HIM?
>> Mitch: LOOK, I THINK THE
MUELLER REPORT IS SOMETHING THAT
THE PRESIDENT OUGHT TO BE HAPPY
ABOUT.
HE BASICALLY SAID WHAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS HOPING TO HEAR.
AND I THINK ONCE IT IS REVEALED
AS MUCH OF IT THAT CAN LEGALLY
BE REVEALED, THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE APPLAUDING IT.
>> Bret: SENATE WATCHERS AND
THERE ARE A LOT OF THEM COME AT
THE AGENDA AND THE SENATE IS
PRETTY LIMITED, RESTRICTED --
RESTRICTED MOSTLY TO NOMINEES.
>> Mitch: THAT IS PARTIALLY
TRUE BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATIC
HOUSE IS NOT LIKELY TO TAKE UP
OUR BEST IDEAS.
WE ARE NOT LIKELY TO TAKE UP
THEIR'S.
ON THE OTHER HAND, PERSONNEL IS
IMPORTANT TO THE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES.
30 CIRCUIT COURT JUSTICES, THE
MOST IN THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF
ANY ADMINISTRATION IN HISTORY.
WE'VE DONE SEVEN MORE CIRCUITS
AND NOW IT'S 37.
WE HAVE 53 DISTRICT JUDGE IS
BACKED UP WITH LIFETIME
APPOINTMENTS THAT WOULD MAKE A
HUGE IMPACT ON THE COUNTRY IN
THE FUTURE.
NOW THAT WE HAVE MODIFIED THE
RULES IN A WAY TO ALLOW US TO
EXPEDITE THESE APPOINTMENTS, WE
WILL DO ALL OF THE DISTRICT
JUDGES.
THAT IS NOT UNIMPORTANT.
THAT WILL HAVE THE LONGEST
IMPACT ON THE COUNTRY OF
ANYTHING WE DO.
>> Bret: LEGISLATIVELY, ONE OF
THE THINGS YOU HAVE MAJOR VOTES
ON AND YOU MENTIONED IT, TO
CRITICIZE DEMOCRATS AND VOTE ON
THE GREEN NEW DEAL TO PUT
DEMOCRAT PRESIDENTIAL HOPEFULS
ON THIS AND ON THE RECORD.
YOU'D DECRIED SHOW BOATS DURING
THE GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
HOW WAS THAT NOT A SHOWBOAT?
>> Mitch: WELCOME IT WAS BUT I
DON'T INTEND TO SPEND ALL OF
OUR TIME DOING THAT BUT ONCE IN
A WHILE THEY NEED TO GO ON THE
RECORD TO VOTE FOR WHAT THEY SAY
THEY ARE FOR.
I MEAN, WE HAD THE GREEN NEW
DEAL ONLY FOUR DEMOCRATS VOTED
AGAINST IT AND INCLUDING THE
PEOPLE WHO COSPONSORED IT.
I THINK WE SHOULD ASSUME THE
REST ARE IN FAVOR OF THIS JOB
KILLING PROPOSAL.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK CONGRESS
SHOULD DO ANYTHING TO FIGHT
CLIMATE CHANGE?
>> Mitch: YEAH I BELIEVE
CLIMATE CHANGE AND CERTAINLY
HAPPENED AND OUGHT TO BE
ADDRESSED BY TECHNOLOGY AND NOT
BY HAVING THE GOVERNMENT SHUT
DOWN OUR ECONOMY AND CAUSE US TO
LOSE AN INCREDIBLE NUMBER OF
JOBS.
>> Bret: SPEAKING OF
SHUTDOWNS, WILL THERE BE ANOTHER
SHUTDOWN IN THE POLL?
>> Mitch: NO.
>> Bret: WIFE?
>> Mitch: IT'S NOT A SENSIBLE
THING TO DO.
I DON'T BELIEVE WE WILL DO THAT
AGAIN.
WE DO NEED TO DO IN ORDER TO
AVOID THAT AND I'VE SPOKE WITH
THE SPEAKER AND PRESIDENT THE
LAST FEW DAYS.
WE HAVE CONVENED A DISCUSSION TO
SEE IF WE CAN AGREE ON HOW MUCH
TO SPEND THIS YEAR AND NEXT YEAR
TO AVOID JUST THAT KIND OF
THING.
>> Bret: THE DEMOCRATS PULLED
OFF OF THE BUDGET VOTE THE OTHER
DAY.
WHAT IS YOUR RELATIONSHIP FOR
NANCY PELOSI?
CAN YOU CHARACTERIZE IT?
>> Mitch: I LIKE NANCY PELOSI.
WE HAVE KNOWN EACH OTHER FOR
YEARS.
SO THERE IS NO PERSONAL
ANIMOSITY.
WE HAVE VERY DIFFERENT VIEWS,
BUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
GIVEN US A DIVIDED GOVERNMENT.
IN ORDER FOR THE GOVERNMENT TO
FUNCTION, WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
DISCUSS THESE THINGS WITH EACH
OTHER AND WE WILL DO THAT WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON THIS ISSUE
THIS YEAR OR NEXT YEAR.
>> Bret: IS THERE ANYTHING
HEADING INTO THE ELECTION
SEASON, ONE ELECTION AWAY FROM
US HOLDING BIG THINGS IT SEEMS
COMEAU AND A CHANCE BIPARTISAN
DEALS ON DRUG PRICES?
>> POSSIBLY.
>> Bret: INFRASTRUCTURE?
>> Mitch: IF WE CAN DEAL WITH
HOW TO PAY FOR IT.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING THE
PRESIDENT A COUPLE OF YEARS NOW.
IF YOU WANT TO DO A REALLY
SIGNIFICANT FROM A LARGE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, WE NEED A
LOT OF STRAIGHT TALK FROM
EVERYBODY ON BOTH SIDES HOW TO
PAY FOR IT.
>> Bret: IMMIGRATION?
>> Mitch: WE DESPERATELY NEED
IMMIGRATION LEGISLATION IN THE
PRESENT IS ENTIRELY CORRECT AT
THE CRISIS AT THE BORDER AND THE
FACT IMMIGRATION LAWS DO NOT
ALLOW US TO DEAL WITH THE CRISIS
AT THE BORDER.
I WOULD HOPE THAT FINALLY AFTER
YEARS OF GRIDLOCK ON THIS COME
UP BY THE WAY, IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT 20 OH NINE AND 2010
DEMOCRATS CONTROLLED THE ENTIRE
GOVERNMENT THEY NEVER BROUGHT UP
IMMIGRATION REFORM, NEVER.
IT IS FINALLY TIME TO STEP UP
AND OPENLY SOLVE THE CRISIS OF
THE BORDER, BUT DO SOME CHANGES
TO IMMIGRATION LAWS THAT ARE
SENSIBLE.
>> Bret: IS THAT DURING THE
SUMMER?
>> Mitch: YES, WE HAVE TO DO
THAT.
AND WE WILL TACKLE THAT AT SOME
POINT.
>> Bret: WHICH DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE DO YOU
FEAR THE MOST?
>> Mitch: [LAUGHTER]
YOU KNOW I WILL NOT ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
I WILL TELL YOU THIS, I THINK
ANY DEMOCRAT WHO WINS THE
NOMINATION WILL SAY, OF COURSE
I'M A CAPITALIST.
I THINK WHAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
WHETHER ADVOCATING THAT WHAT
THEY CALL THEMSELVES BY ANY
DEMOCRAT WHO IS SYMPATHETIC TO
PECKING THE SUPREME COURT AND
GETTING RID OF ELECTORAL
COLLEGE, GREEN NEW DEAL,
MEDICARE FOR ALL, IN MY VIEW
TAKING AMERICA AND THE DIRECTION
OF SOCIALISM.